[Music]
look at live pictures of Capitol Hill
steps from where we're sitting right now
the house is currently setting up the
rules for the impeachment vote they're
apparently going to hold tomorrow houses
temporarily in recess is gonna be
reconvening in about a half an hour
we're monitoring the situation there
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight it is here after months
of false starts and threats and endless
posturing by some of the saddest most
ineffectual people in America
impeachment apparently is imminent
barring some last-minute plot twist and
that could happen but otherwise less
than 24 hours from now Donald Trump will
join Andrew Johnson and Bill Clinton as
the third American president ever
impeached by the House of
Representatives we're thinking at this
point the final vote tomorrow afternoon
so Democrats been promising to do this
since before the president was even
elected president and yet still it feels
kind of weird surprising surreal even
that it's finally going to happen why
because impeachment there's really no
disagreement about this is a terrible
idea for the country at this point
there's no question that Democrats can't
actually remove the president and in
trying they will only hurt themselves
the polls are clear and yet and here's
the fascinating point they're doing it
anyway watch Maryland congressman Jamie
Raskin explain why they're doing it the
president's continuing course of conduct
constitutes a clear and present danger
to democracy in America we cannot allow
this misconduct to pass it would be a
sellout of our Constitution our foreign
policy our national security and our
democracy see if you can follow the
logic chain maybe you can spot the
missing link here's what he's arguing
leaving a president in office until
voters can decide to remove them from
office if they want is quote a danger to
democracy it's a quote sellout of our
Constitution okay
so in case you've forgotten what is the
crime that undergirds this impeachment
proceeding what is the president accused
of doing well in case you've forgotten
it's the Donald Trump
may have delayed military aid to the
government of Ukraine now keep in mind
that the only purpose of aid to the
government of Ukraine is to antagonize
Russia keep in mind also that Russia is
a country with more nuclear weapons than
any other country on the globe but
according to Jamie Raskin not giving
weapons to Ukraine is a clear and
present danger to America it's a sellout
he says of our national security to
pause in our relentless attacks on
Russia even for a moment that's a
remarkable assertion hard to believe he
could defend that in a rational
conversation but it doesn't even stand
out under the current standards of
political rhetoric there's a lot of talk
like that all of a sudden the entire
impeachment saga in fact has become
detached from reality here are the most
basic facts about it Democrats do not
have the votes to remove President Trump
from office they never will have the
votes to remove the president the point
of impeachment is to remove a president
they cannot do that this process is
doomed before it even begins and by the
way they don't have the votes because
voters don't support it the irony is
that our democracy is working just fine
voters support it in fact less than they
did after a full month of watching
public hearings on impeachment Democrats
have not gained support they have lost
it in late October when this began about
half the country backed impeachment 44%
said they were opposed to impeachment in
the most recent polling those numbers
have inverted in other words the more
people learned about impeachment the
less they wanted impeachment that's not
one person's opinion that is the sum
total of the polling the numbers could
not be clearer on this question and yet
even in the face of all those data a
leap Democrats still will not admit it
they're literally in denial
watch Democratic Party cheerleader
Jeffrey Toobin attack his own company's
polling when it doesn't match what he
believes must be true you see a decline
from our last poll in Democratic support
from ninety percent down to 77 percent
did I just say my twin brother that I
don't believe that
hold for one second partner 92 77% I you
know it's just I don't believe it with
like it makes no sense that that number
would change like that I mean you know
life mean in life has shown us that
polls are sometimes wrong and David that
poll is wrong just as I said okay
[Laughter]
because I don't because I look out my
window and I see the horizon that means
it's flat you can tell me the earth is
round but I just don't believe it enough
with your dumb numbers in your
scientific theories I just don't believe
it says the legal analyst okay
what's your watching obviously is one
man degrade himself but it's bigger than
that it's the definition of ideological
extremism and that's the inability to
change course no matter what the
evidence tells you so that's the point
at which this is no longer politics of
course we left that a long time ago what
you're looking at is religion and of
course being the Democratic Party and
their religion it's always the exact
opposite of what they claim it is so as
President Trump noted in a recent letter
to Nancy Pelosi and we're quoting you
are the ones interfering in America's
elections you are the ones subverting
American democracy you are the ones
bringing pain and suffering to a
republic for your own selfish personal
political and partisan game the public
whether they like Trump or not agrees
with that the polling shows it but the
Democrats can't acknowledge that they're
stuck so in 2016 they went all in on
denouncing Trump remember this before
the election and every one of his
supporters you as beyond the pale racist
worthy of being hated not reason with
her talked to but hated it and dismissed
and physically assaulted in some cases
what they lost anyway when they did lose
they refused to learn they refused to
even think for a moment about why they
may have lost and instead moves
seamlessly from racism into a conspiracy
about Russia so bizarre they could never
even fully explain its outlines what are
you saying you would ask Russia they
would say okay that collapsed you
watched it happen on live television but
what hasn't changed you
rage storm they created with years of
propaganda they whipped their voters
into such a frenzy that the voters can't
be pulled back now they want blood and
so Democrats have no choice but to march
forward despite the fact that it will
inevitably destroy them and they know it
will it's poignant almost